dos personas parten del mismo punto
ambos en la misma dirección y ambos a la
misma hora a las nueve de la mañana uno
de ellos va caminando mientras que el
otro va trotando la velocidad promedio
de la persona que va trotando es un
kilómetro por hora más lenta que el
doble de la velocidad promedio de la
persona que va caminando esta va a ser
una de nuestras ecuaciones dejan
subrayarla en dos horas la persona que
va trotando está tres kilómetros
adelante de la persona que va caminando
aquí tenemos otra ecuación y después
dice encuentra la velocidad de la
persona que va a trotando y bueno lo
primero que vamos a hacer es escribir
esta primera oración como una ecuación y
dice la velocidad promedio de la persona
que va trotando es decir lo voy a
escribir como p subíndice t la velocidad
promedio de la persona que va trotando
es igual a 2 veces la velocidad de la
persona que va caminando menos un
kilómetro por hora es justo lo que nos
dice esta primera oración pero aquí ya
está escrita en matemáticas
y que la velocidad promedio de la
persona que trotan es un kilómetro por
hora más lenta que la velocidad promedio
de la persona que camina y ahora la otra
oración me dice que después de dos horas
la persona que va trotando está tres
kilómetros después de la persona que va
caminando esto lo voy a escribir como
distancia la distancia después de dos
horas de la persona que va trotando es
decir la distancia de su 27mo esto va a
ser igual a la misma distancia que
recorrió la persona que va caminando es
decir de subíndices cm más tres
kilómetros y bueno parece que esto no
tiene sentido una ecuación habla de
velocidad y la otra de distancia de
distancia después de dos horas es decir
tenemos un tiempo en común y entonces
como parece que tenemos dos ecuaciones
muy extrañas lo que voy a hacer es
recordar la siguiente fórmula que es muy
importante siempre tenerla a la mano hay
que recordar que la distancia es igual a
la velocidad por el tiempo pero el
tiempo siempre va a ser dos horas porque
la segunda ecuación que tenemos nos
habla de la distancia que recorrieron
después d
dos horas de trayecto y entonces ahora
sí utilizando esta información voy a
cambiar esta ecuación que tengo de aquí
y me va a quedar que la distancia de la
persona que va trotando es igual a 2 por
la velocidad de la persona que va
trotando porque transcurrieron 2 horas y
estoy utilizando la fórmula de aquí
arriba y de igual manera si yo tengo en
la distancia de la persona que va
caminando esto es igual a 2 porque son
dos horas por la velocidad de la persona
que va caminando lo único que estoy
haciendo sustituyendo estos valores de
la distancia en términos de los valores
de la velocidad utilizando la fórmula
que escribí aquí arriba y ahora sí si
nosotros ponemos esta nueva ecuación
aquí abajo me va a quedar que dos veces
la velocidad de la persona que va
trotando pues esto es igual a dos veces
caminando más tres lo único que estoy
haciendo es escribiendo esta ecuación
que tengo aquí la derecha aquí abajo
para que reciba utilicemos algún método
para resolver este sistema de ecuaciones
simultáneamente
date cuenta que lo más importante de
este ejercicio fue darme cuenta que
podríamos escribir a la distancia en
función de la velocidad utilizando la
fórmula de aquí arriba y bueno como
resolvemos este sistema de ecuaciones
pues se me ocurre que lo más fácil es
multiplicar esta ecuación de arriba por
menos la voy a multiplicar todo por
menos 1 y entonces aquí me quedan menos
aquí también me quedan menos y después
menos 1 por menos 1 es el mismo que 1
positivo ohl +1 ya así ya tengo dos
ecuaciones y se van a cancelar estas dos
entonces si yo sumo ambos lados la
ecuación del lado izquierdo me queda
menos la velocidad de la persona que va
trotando más dos veces la velocidad de
la persona que va trotando pues
solamente me queda la velocidad de la
persona que va trotando una vez esa
velocidad estos dos se cancelan y
después me queda 13 13 es 4 y ya está y
además está de lujo porque era justo lo
que me pedían encuentra la velocidad de
la persona que va trotando la velocidad
de la persona que va tratando son 4
kilómetros por hora
si también quisiéramos la velocidad de
la persona que va caminando entonces
vamos a sustituir este valor en la
ecuación de arriba de la ecuación de
arriba originalmente se veía si la
velocidad de la persona que va tratando
es igual a 2 veces la velocidad de la
persona que va caminando menos 1 si
sustituimos el valor de la velocidad que
va trotando me quedaría que 4 es igual a
2 de zubin de ccm menos 1 sumando uno de
ambos lados después dividiendo entre 2
me quedaría que b subíndice cm es igual
a cinco medios kilómetros por hora la
velocidad promedio de la persona que va
caminando es de 2.5 kilómetros por horas
sin embargo esta es la respuesta de mi
problema